Hẵn Tinh vóa tư, nghe một món thư bộ dâu mòn đầu sắc nhận với ngày mai lập dâu nước này,
đánh nối lại nhập hộ dâu thư từ Ivan Saubà năm 2018.
Đây là là nổ tiên kịt ngâm hành nghiệm phung chân chính,
khi nếu đi liên ngường bộ dâu Ivan Sau có lệnh trường phạt của Mỹ,
đồng thách sĩnh xa trương bố cảnh 1 con năng lượng tàn cầu biện đường nghiêm trọng,
bởi xung đột tại trưng đông và sáng đoạn vận tại của Ivan Saubà năm 2018.
Bộ dâu mòn đầu cũng chờ biết,
bình nhập thậu tới Ivan được thực hiện mà không gặp trường hại vì thánh toán,
đồng thời nhấn mạnh,
nhưng này đã em bảo đảng đủ 1 con trưng những tháng tới.
Chúng đỏ Mỹ đã tạm thường nối là một số bệnh phát trường phạt lối với dòng mọi Ivan,
nhằm giảm ả lực thiếu hồ chí thi trường.
Anh độ của Saatu Thủ sau lớn thứ 8 thì dởi cho biết,
các suân nghiệp trong nước có quyền lợi trọng 1 con,
từ hong 1 môi của Sai dự chình như tu thương mạnh.
Chúng ki đó Ivan ngừng tìm kếc duy trị xuất khẩu năng lượng,
cho bởi cảnh chục như SFF,
có truy ra năng lượng nhận định việc nối lại sông dịch của thế có phản động định thị trường.
Saam cũng phản nán như un điều trình liên quả của KUSA,
cho biến động định chính trị hiện này.